los angeles civil court jury has found
bill cosby sexually assaulted a minor
nearly 50 years ago now this is the
latest in a series of cases involving
the comedian and former sitcom star
judy huth is her name she is now 64. she
was awarded half a million dollars in
damages after suing bill cosby now he
denies the allegation and his lawyers
say that he will appeal this verdict our
national correspondent jerica duncan has
more on the story
bill cosby was found liable tuesday for
the sexual assault of judy huff at the
playboy mansion in 1975 when she was 16
years old i was elated seriously it's
been so many years so many tears just a
long time coming hoth joined her
attorney outside the courthouse after
the verdict she fought bill cosby
one step at a time
for over seven and a half years during
the trial huff testified as to her
chance meeting with cosby while he was
filming a movie at a park she said cosby
gave her alcohol and eventually led her
to a bedroom at the playboy mansion
where he molested and sexually assaulted
her the jury found that cosby
intentionally caused harmful sexual
conduct with huff and that he reasonably
believed she was under 18. huff was
awarded 500 thousand dollars in damages
for emotional distress cosby
spokesperson said the comedian would
appeal the verdict what happened today
wasn't a victory they didn't get the
punitive damages the juror's decision
marks a major defeat for the now 84 year
old who had recently been experiencing a
series of legal victories last year his
2018 sexual assault conviction in a
separate criminal case was overturned
and in march the u.s supreme court
announced it would not review that case
leaving cosby a free man yesterday's
decision offered a degree of comfort to
other alleged victims of abuse by cosby
like chelan lasha i feel very proud this
moment
we have a long way to go
it's a lot of us still left out here in
pain every day once called america's dad
cosby has consistently denied all
accounts of sexual misconduct for cbs
morning's jerika duncan new york